Солдату з Вірменії важко долати цю стіну спекотним і парким сибірським літом.
Це лише одна з понад 20 перешкод на полігоні. Судді стежать, щоб ніхто з учасників не махлював
і не скоротив дистанції, аби досягти кращого часового результату.
Армійські міжнародні ігри - це типово російське дітище. Одразу ж після анексії Криму і вторгнення на Донбас, у 2015 році
російське міноборони вирішило демонструвати своє дружнє обличчя арміям світу і запрошувати їх на змагання.
Міжнародні ігри відбуваються вже втретє, утім, коло охочих взяти в них учась доволі вузьке.
Нам би хотілося подивитися на рівень підготовки американців, німців, французів, британців. Це було б справді цікаво.
Однак це питання наших дипломатів, нашого керівництва досягти домовленостей. Одного дня це станеться. Ми би хотіли їх бачити тут.
Серед країн, які приїхали на запрошення російської сторони - Казахстан, Вірменія, а також Китай, Іран та Зімбабве.
Звичайно є відмінності у підходах і тактиках. Але армія - це армія. Спілкуватися важко, однак порозумітися не дуже важко.
Російські військові демонструють гостям перетин уявної лінії фронту і вміння залазити на стовпи з 20-ма кілограмами амуніції.
Проте перепони у співпраці РФ з країнами Заходу зовсім інші: це анексія Криму та агресія на Донбасі.